yeah
that's an interesting theory
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at vegan lifestyle youtuber ashley
alexander otherwise known as your mom
ashley but first let me tell you about
my sponsor bill barr it is snack time in
my house and i'm really super excited
because today i got a brand new box of
build bars and these are legit my
favorite right now because i got the
granola bars
so billbar came out with these three new
granola bar flavors white chocolate
berry chocolate peanut butter and
chocolate coconut and i'm totally in
love with the chewy granola texture
let's get into one
[Applause]
[Music]
if you like texture and different
flavors and like a little chocolate a
little sweet little tangy sour cherry in
there oh my goodness these are good like
they taste like a chocolate bar but with
15 grams of protein and if you want to
like step up your breakfast game you put
this on top of some oatmeal or start
with some fruit you're going to love
your life so
so
much so if you want to try out these
build bars yourself check out my link in
the description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on tick tock and instagram at abby's
kitchen so this one was highly requested
so let's just get right into it because
your girl is feeling hungry and this is
probably not gonna help this morning i'm
gonna be starting out by making some
tofu scramble
[Music]
scramble avocado toast that i didn't
season yet okay tofu scramble is an
amazing vegan alternative to scrambled
eggs and i love that it doesn't cut any
nutritional corners so we're still
getting tons of protein from the tofu
and nutritional yeast healthy fats from
the avocado and lots of fiber and
micronutrients from the frozen veggies
bread and the spinach i'd say aside from
the cost of avocados right now i would
call this a pretty affordable meal to
like satisfy a crowd and since ashley is
vegan we definitely want to make sure
that we're paying attention to some of
the specific nutrients of concern like
calcium vitamin b12 iron zinc and
vitamin d and it looks like she's doing
a great job hitting those marks bravo
bravo so we're getting iron and calcium
from the spinach zinc and calcium from
the tofu and a healthy dose of vitamin
b12 from the nutritional yeast as well
as loads of protein in fact only two
teaspoons of fortified nutritional yeast
provides over 300 percent of the daily
recommendation for vitamin b12 now the
key here with both tofu and nooch is to
check the label so you want to look for
fortified nutritional yeast and calcium
set tofu or calcium sulfate tofu which
has 10 times the calcium content of
non-calcium set this is so colorful my
mom always told me nutrients it's
important to eat colorful foods your mom
knows what's up and this is why i like
to say we want to count our colors not
our calories because color is a good
indicator of phytonutrient and
antioxidant diversity which we know is
really good for our health color also
just ups the sensory experience of
eating and research also suggests that
we're much more likely to eat meals that
just look aesthetically good i also have
to say that i love their roomy family
meal time healthy eating is not just
about the nutrients on your plate
research suggests that regular family or
social meals have physical and mental
health benefits and are associated with
decreased feelings of loneliness and
increased happiness and life
satisfaction i mean just try to think
back to like 2020 or whenever your
country got out of quarantine for the
first time like up here in canada i'm
pretty sure it was just like last month
you go outside and you'll die but you
know
that that first post-quarantine family
or friends meal just hit different so
satisfying we need more of that in our
life i ordered ashley a vegan banana
bread mmm thanks kelly we have our
drinks coming as well
spiced matcha latte with almond milk
latte with almond milk because ashley
doesn't drink oat milk right now because
it's bad for her skin or something like
that but i'm breaking out around my face
that vegan banana bread and iced matcha
combo looks delicious if she needed a
more sustaining pick-me-up between meals
she could choose a higher protein milk
like soy or add like a little bit of nut
butter on the bread just to turn it into
a hunger crushing combo but is the oat
milk hate here warranted to promote
clear skin well i have a whole video on
the relationship between food and acne
which you can watch right here but to
quickly summarize we do have research to
suggest that certain foods may increase
the occurrence of acne specifically
foods that have a high glycemic index
like refined carbs and sugar and this is
because sugar increases our insulin
levels triggering the hormone igf-1
which has been shown to worsen acne
symptoms by increasing sebum production
so one large study found that frequent
consumption of high gi foods was
associated with a 30 increase in
developing acne among teens now oat milk
isn't exactly like eating candy but it
does have a medium glycemic load with 16
to 18 grams of carbs per cup anna has
very little protein or fat to
essentially slow down the absorption of
those carbs so i suppose if you drink a
lot of it it could theoretically be
triggering for some however like most
things acne breakouts are highly
individualized and lifestyle factors
like diet are only one small piece of
the clear skin puzzle so ashley may
break out from a single oat milk latte
while her friend kelly's skin might be
completely fine but if switching to
almond milk works better for ashley and
her skin then totally works for me
[Music]
okay so i just finished up the edamame
bowls i'm still working on making the
burritos right now now let's eat some
lunch
epic success this is actually i think
the first time i've successfully rolled
a burrito well i'm literally so proud of
this this is like my baby again i am
loving the easy peasy meals and roomy
lunch time i also think that these are
great examples of really versatile and
customizable meals even for folks who
aren't vegan but who still want to share
that meal without sacrificing flavor or
nutrition i especially love that we're
getting a variety of plant-based protein
sources that deliver a nice array of
amino acids but just a heads up on vegan
protein we used to think that we needed
to combine incomplete sources of protein
like rice and beans together in like the
exact same meal to form a complete
protein with all of the essential amino
acids that the body needs in that one
single meal but we now know that our
body is way smarter than that not a lot
research suggests as long as we're
eating a variety of protein sources and
enough calories overall there's no
reason to worry about whether the
protein you're eating is complete or
incomplete this also speaks to why
there's very little evidence to suggest
that following a plant-based diet
increases the risk of protein deficiency
which i know is a very common concern
amongst the omnivore community for
vegans and vegetarians the only concern
that we do have with vegan diets and
protein is that plant-based proteins
tend to have slightly lower
bioavailability and absorption profiles
compared to animal-based protein which
is why it's often recommended that
vegans and vegetarians slightly
overshoot their protein intake so for
example the basic daily protein
recommendation for vegans is around 1
gram of protein per kilogram of body
weight a day compared to 0.8 grams of
protein per kilogram for non-vegans this
basically nets out to like a 14 gram
increase in protein for someone who's
vegan and weighs around 140 pounds
compared to a non-vegan of the same
weight we also want to try to pair that
plant-based protein with a source of
vitamin c from things like fruits and
vegetables to really help the absorption
which i've seen ashley do often but the
bottom line is as long as you're eating
enough total calories your food options
aren't heavily restricted like in the
case of a ketotarian or fruitarian diet
and you're switching up your protein
sources day to day there's really no
reason to worry your girl ashley seems
to have this down
mustard green crispy chicken orange
chicken
honestly tastes pretty good
i've never had a stuffed jalapeno this
is stuffed with like some type of like
protein or something it's good this is
kelly's absolute favorite thing i grew
up eating a lot of spanish because my
grandma would make it for me now i'm
eating the vegetarian version
that looks so good you know a lot of
people ask me if they can be vegan and
still eat intuitively and to that i say
oh yes intuitive eating is about
self-care it's not just about eating
whatever you want so when the intention
behind limiting animal products is not
related to changing your body and we're
giving ourselves unconditional
permission to enjoy let's say like a
vegan fried chicken or vegan sushi we
tend not to feel trapped in the diet
cycle of deprivation and denial
thankfully there are so many more vegan
options that make this paradigm shift
possible for folks who want to take it
on as long as these options still feel
satisfying to you and you're not
limiting yourself of the vegan
alternatives this is still of course
compatible with intuitive eating but in
ashley's meal specifically we're getting
some more protein variety with the
crispy chicken and the orange chicken
which according to the happy veggie
website are made with soy and wheat
protein the mustard greens also provide
a calcium and iron boost which are key
nutrients of concern on a vegan diet and
then of course we've got lots of fun
stuff like the jalapeno poppers dragon
rolls and most importantly a really fun
family style meal so lots of good stuff
to love what are my overall thoughts on
ashley's diet well based on our rough
calculations it looks like ashley's
consuming enough calories for her needs
and i'm seeing around a solid 90 grams
or so of protein from a wide variety of
protein sources plus lots of sources of
calcium iron and b12 so she clearly has
this plant-based nutrition thing down
and despite choosing a vegan diet i
never got any sense that she's
intentionally restricting in any way in
fact we watched a bunch of videos like
looking for red flags and unless we miss
something specific which is of course
always possible we obviously can't watch
everything we really didn't catch any
red flags
she seems to genuinely enjoy preparing
eating and sharing her meals with her
roomies which i think is awesome plus
all of her meals were super balanced and
easy to prepare and i love the
combination of homemade and takeaway
ingredients and meals overall i think
ashley is super fun low fuss and
definitely knows how to do a vegan diet
justice so on that note that is all that
i have for you guys today if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]